is a story of a couple
who are having some issues and
challenges in their relationship
they cross the bridge and they're lost
in a town that is an old movie musical
as long as they have a
functioning toilet i'm in the town is
in an alternate universe the town is a
musical
and now they're stuck in that musical
why is
music coming from everywhere
the people in schmidt don't sort of
realize they're unusual they don't
realize they're singing
either which is hilarious that was a
very
handsome song what song shmegadoon is
colorful
and fun and everything is sung
you know much i hate musicals people
don't just burst into song in real life
and then of course as we get to pull the
layers back a little bit you get to see
that it's not so perfect as it might
look from the outset the whole thing is
supposed to feel
so surreal there's this beautiful mix of
present day reality and very much an
old world sensibility it is we
the mothers against the future so you're
against
the passage of time it's a star-studded
cast that's
so good at musical theater and really
bringing all that
broadway experience has been amazing it
was a dazzling cast
on top of cinco's great creativity and
barry sonnenfeld's vision
what i liked about cinco's scripts were
a they were very funny
and b cinco has written fantastic
songs
for she says so what's the plan josh
look for someone new
i'm not having a discussion that's part
of a musical number we're all so
fortunate that barry sonnenfeld
was the person who signed on to direct
us and it's so stylized and beautiful
but at the same time
we are still telling a funny and
emotionally grounded story
oh you're not going to want to drink
that missy that there's the gentleman's
punch bowl
it's got alcohol in it thank you for the
warning
larry the fireman we are giving a love
letter to music theater you are gonna
laugh your butt off
and you also might shed a tear the
characters are wonderful
and the songs are wonderful and the sets
are beautiful
the acting is perfection
it's just different than what you're
used to seeing on tv you're gonna be
watching something magical for these six
episodes
do you think this is true love there's
so much to enjoy
you're sitting down and smiling the
whole time
[Music]
[Applause]
yay you guys did that can we please go
now
you